une page spectacle à présent avec eux
celle à celle à qui et à bordeaux pour
un concert unique à la patinoire de
bordeaux ce soir à 21h et les narines
seine et jean paul it et l'ont
rencontrée au moment d'une répétition
ils ont voulu en savoir plus sur lâcher
la crue 85
celle à qui nous avoue d'abord aimer le
football puisqu'il hier soir elle était
comme vous et moi je suppose derrière
son téléviseur pour le match juventus
bordeaux
j'ai la chance de venir hier donc j'ai
vécu le match ici sur place
nous avons un petit plateau dans ma
chambre d'hôtel et je veux dire qu'après
je me suis baladé un peu dans la ville
pour voir pour voir ce qui se passait
pour voir la ville que je ne connais pas
et pour voir la réaction des gens
je crois que tout bordeaux a été
complètement polarisée par le match que
tout à fait logique et normal bien
entendu vous n'allez pas coupé à la
question les couettes c'est fini celle à
85 qui sait je pense que c'est quelqu'un
qui à 20 ans de plus qui a eu plein de
d'expérience dans la vie je crois que je
suis une
une femme qui s'assume qui fait un
métier qu'elle adore qui a une vie
passionnante et qui qui essaie de faire
les choses qu'elle fait avec beaucoup
d'amour et beaucoup de de plein de
choses que je mets toute ma vie
là-dedans j'aime chanter je suis assez
bon dans très longtemps sans faire de
spectacle et de seine pour moi je repars
en tournée c'est mon premier soir que ce
soit je vais partir pendant quinze jours
et après cet été et je veux dire que
c'est passionnant parce que c'est une
vie de baladins et c'est quand même la
vie d'un artiste avant tout
j'ai la chance de de travailler d'être
quelqu'un les pieds sur la terre qui a
appris à travailler sur les marchés qui
est sort d'un milieu ouvrier et je pense
que c'est ça a été ma plus belle école
pourquoi ce silence au niveau du
spectacle 19 ans de silence ça je peux
vous devriez poser la question à claude
carrère mais je sais pas parce que j'ai
travaillé avec quelqu'un qui a été qui
était totalement contre la scène
peut-être parce qu'il a oublié qu'il
avait affaire à un artiste mais qu'il a
beaucoup pensé à son porte-monnaie mais
en face aussi dit je suis pas là pour
régler mes comptes je m'en fous c'est
très bien de faire ça maintenant parce
que je me dis oh moi ça fait 20 ans que
je chante et du côté du spectacle je
suis pas encore usées je suis tout neufs
j'ai tout à apprendre ou au tout du
moins beaucoup de choses à découvrir
donc c'est fabuleux
je suis la plus heureuse des femmes j'ai
tout pour être heureuse je fais un
métier que j'aime j'ai la chance de
faire de sales depuis longtemps de
démarrer une nouvelle carrière est
entouré de gens jeunes d'avoir beaucoup
d'amour autour de moi et j'espère ce
soir avoir un public fabuleux à bordeaux